wir als erstes im team und die leitung
nach drei kommen und wie man sky die
hand geben alle impossible austausch der
kunst über kunst und da kommt man hat
ziemlich schnell ins gespräch stoff hat
man eigentlich sofort ja es war bislang
gespannte stimmung wieder einmal als
neue leiter muss man nicht kennt aber es
ist an der zeit war das schlager oder
maschinell geköpft
ein ganzkörper chips stationen erste
wahl ist deine daten kult und zu schauen
ob die viel geändert ost zweite war
urintest recht aber blutdruck und
impfung danach war frank zu beantworten
ob das schon mal falle zu meinem kopf
horst während einer allergie in horst
erweiterungen haben sie untersucht augen
nicht und am schluss gibt es dann ein
kleines gespräch mit mit der ärztin was
in unserem fall die den markt für steve
aus dem einschränkungen und solche dinge
danach wurden kurze belehrung im
lehrsaal da ist um sagen wie fahrtkosten
unter gleichen gegangen
das war nämlich mit der bundeswehr
vorteilscard und dem wert ist das weiß
nämlich gerade das in ganz österreich
fahren darf und so weiter diese sachen
halt wohnkosten förderung und solche
sachen werden auch gesprochen
das besondere muss ich sagen war heute
das uniform aus phasen und da ist man
halt spannend war es dann einen erwartet
was man mit dem ganzen dinge macht der
herbst und vorgelesen was eben in dieser
ausrüstung drinnen sein muss und wir
haben geschaut dass auch der preis und
wenn einige dinge gefehlt haben dann
wurden die ersetzt und so damit wir eben
alle eine vollständige ausrüstung haben
es schaut nicht schlecht aus einfach
wenn dann zehn leute zum beispiel eben
in der gleichen uniform nebeneinander
gehen
es gibt ja eigentlich ein gutes bild
leben wie das gibt einem auch ein
bisschen selbstvertrauen und alles und
eben ja es ist ein super gefühl sie zu
überarbeiten nur druck sozusagen etwas
besonderes kunst trotzt jeder ich finde
es super
sorgen viele geschichten gehört im
vorfeld von freunden feiern wollten ein
bisschen angst machen natürlich dass
gerade volleyball ein schlichtung wollen
diesen auch mal an nehmen
aber ich muss sagen es ist ziemlich
locker und gegangen also bis jetzt neues
super im jahr am anfang war es heute ein
bisschen stressig weil wir uns einfach
überhaupt nicht ausgekannt haben wo was
ist und so doch dann habe neben uns die
unteroffiziere eben in der kaserne
herumgeführt und uns alles gezeigt wo
wir hingehen sollen wenn wir das und das
brauchen jetzt kennen wir uns schon ein
bisschen aus und jetzt ist auch die
nervosität die erste irgendwie verflogen
und es ist einfach wird's langsam schon
zum normalen alltag